par un changement de la loi en matière
de recours en matière d'usage de la
force par la police le gouvernement sera
interrogé à ce sujet par la gauche
Elisabeth borne sera interpellé par le
président du groupe socialiste
patrickner elle devra donc afficher la
position du Gouvernement en la matière
et puis autre thème autre question cet
après-midi il sera question du port de
voile du port du voile sur les terrains
de foot un collectif à saisie le Conseil
d'État pour obtenir la possibilité de
porter le hijab pour les joueuses de
foot du côté du gouvernement on est
opposé le Conseil d'État rendra sa
décision définitive demain jeudi il
faudra-t-il passer par une interdiction
par la loi à ce sujet et bien les
sénateurs interpelleront le gouvernement
afin d'avoir une position définitive de
l'exécutif sur la question la droite
évidemment qui pousse pour une
interdiction par la loi du port du voile
sur les terrains de foot dans quelques
instants à présent la séance va débuter
on va suivre cette séance on se retrouve
juste après pour les briques le
compte-rendu analytique de la précédente
séance a été distribué nous n'avons pas
reçu d'observation
il y en a t-il en séance
je n'en vois point le procès-verbal est
donc adopté sous les réserves d'usage
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement je vous
rappelle que la séance est retransmise
en direct sur Public Sénat et sur notre
site internet au nom du bureau du Sénat
rappelle à chacun le respect du temps de
parole et le respect des uns et des
autres je voudrais
saluer particulièrement un huissier
qui a servi le Sénat pendant 21 années
et qui a servi le Sénat pendant 34
années monsieur howare je le cherche des
yeux le voilà il est ici et
tu as besoin de l'occasion de saluer
votre nom à tous tout le travail que
font les huissiers du Sénat à la fois au
service de la séance au service du
protocole et pour l'ensemble de notre
institution je voulais le souligner au
travers de l'exemple de Monsieur ouais
avant de
passer la parole à notre collègue
président Pierre Laurent je sais dans
les secrets qu'il a décidé de ne pas
renouveler son mandat c'est sans doute
pas encore un secret d'État mais je
voudrais mais saluer celui qui est
devenu sénateur de Paris en 2012 son
engagement comme vice-président de notre
commission des affaires étrangères
depuis 3 ans quand le vice-président du
Sénat chargé notamment de l'ensemble de
la vie culturelle du palais et ce qu'on
voit autour du palais et au musée et à
l'Orangerie lui doit beaucoup je
voudrais le remercier pour aussi la
conduite sereine parfois il devait
bouillir en intérieur mais
de nos travaux dans cette émission et il
s'est attaché à le préserver en toute
circonstances mais maintenant je lui
donne la parole comme Miss président
membre du groupe communiste républicain
et citoyen
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre
après le drame survenu hier à Nanterre
l'émotion est très vive dans le pays
j'ai mal à ma France à titre à tweeté
Killian Mbappe 10 ans avec ses mots ce
que ressentent je crois des millions de
jeunes et de parents choqués par la
vidéo du drame on y voit un policier
braquer son arme à bout portant par la
portière du véhicule et tiré
mortellement sur le conducteur un jeune
de 17 ans je pense que cette émotion est
également présente dans les
commissariats de France dans lesquels
beaucoup de fonctionnaires ont ce matin
mal à leur métier
je veux y joindre ici l'émotion de tout
mon groupe devant la douleur de la
famille on ne peut pas mourir à 17 ans
pour un refus d'obtempérer
jeudi ma solidarité à la famille du
jeune Naël je dis également mon soutien
entier au maire de Nanterre Patrick
Jarry et aux élus de cette grande ville
populaire qui vole la vérité la vidéo du
contrôle et du tir et glaçante le
policier a été placé en garde à vue et
mis en examen pour homicide volontaire
par personne dépositaire de l'autorité
publique c'est dire la gravité des
fesses sous mes soumis désormais en
quête la lumière madame la Première
ministre doit être faite dans les
meilleurs délais car ce que nous avons
vu est parfaitement révoltant
l'IGPN doit à la famille la plus grande
transparence et la vérité une enquête
enterrée de plus ne sera pas accepté par
les non-terrians
au-delà de l'enquête qui doit donc
suivre son cours avec rapidité est-il
envisagé madame la Première ministre de
afin de réagir à la mesure des faits
incriminés de prononcer une suspension à
titre conservatoire de l'agent concerné
j'ajoute que la mort de ce jeune homme
n'est malheureusement pas un cas isolé
il y a eu un doublement des nombres de
morts dans ces circonstances depuis 2017
ne serait-il pas tant d'engager la
révision de la doctrine
utilisée dans ces cas-là qui a conduit à
la brutale accélération de ces drames
mortels madame la Première ministre un
pays dans lequel la police et la
jeunesse ne peuvent pas se croiser sans
inquiétude et angoisse est un pays
malade de sa démocratie c'est votre
responsabilité de changer au plus vite
ce climat
merci
pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame la Première ministre madame la
Première ministre
merci monsieur le président
mesdamnateurs
lors d'un contrôle routier un jeune
homme de 17 ans a été tué c'est un
terrible drame et je veux commencer par
dire ma profonde émotion et adresser mes
condoléances à sa famille à ses proches
et à son quartier
le président de la République a eu
l'occasion de le dire ce matin c'est la
Nation toute entière qui est touchée par
ce drame
je me suis entretenu tout à l'heure avec
le maire de Nanterre Patrick Jarry je
lui ai dit mon soutien celui de mon
gouvernement et j'ai partagé avec lui
notre détermination à ce que toute la
vérité soit faite aujourd'hui il y a un
choc un deuil une colère c'est à la
justice d'y répondre je connais
l'engagement de nos policiers et de nos
gendarmes au quotidien sur le terrain
ils savent que porter l'uniforme c'est
répondre à un devoir celui de
l'exemplarité les images choquantes
diffusées hier montre une intervention
qui ne semble manifestement pas conforme
aux règles d'engagement de nos forces de
l'ordre
la justice devra établir les faits elle
a été saisie elle a commencé son travail
un policier est en garde à vue et je
souhaite comme chacun que la vérité soit
faite le plus rapidement possible et que
des réponses soient apportées la justice
passera personne ne doit en douter seul
la justice permettra de faire toute la
lumière sur ce drame
seule la justice apportera des réponses
face à la douleur d'une famille et à la
peine d'une nation seule la justice
garantira notre unité et alors que des
violences ont éclaté cette nuit dans
certains quartiers tout particulièrement
dans les Hauts-de-Seine je veux appeler
chacun à l'apaisement
monsieur le sénateur Pierre Laurent nous
voulons la justice pour Naël et nous
l'obtiendrons mais elle doit être rendue
de manière pacifique ces mots sont ceux
du maire de Nanterre Patrick Jarry je
veux les saluer et avec vous aujourd'hui
je m'y associe je vous remercie
la parole est notre collègue Patricia
Schillinger pour le groupe du
Rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant vous avez
la parole merci monsieur le Président ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur Olivier du
socle ministre du Travail monsieur le
ministre permettez-moi d'associer à
cette question mon collègue Ludovic est
dans deux jours seulement les
dérogations qui permettent de
travailleurs frontaliers qui exerce
ensuite de télétravailler s'achèveront
en réaction à la crise sanitaire la
France est la Suisse ont en effet levé
les restrictions fiscales et sociales
qui freinaient jusque là le recours au
télétravail par les travailleurs
concernés or cette organisation a
largement contribué à l'amélioration de
la qualité de vie de ces travailleurs et
fait particulièrement sens au moment où
l'urgence climatique exige de limiter
notre consommation d'énergie fossiles
j'ai donc à de nombreuses reprises
attirer l'attention du gouvernement j'ai
milité pour une solution pérenne et
favorable télétravail des front
aujourd'hui ces derniers sont inquiets
et craignent qu'au-delà du 30 juin leur
capacité à télétravailler soit nouveau
limitée en décembre dernier un accord
fiscal a été conclu leur permettant de
télétravailler jusqu'à 40 % de leur
temps de travail sans modification des
règles d'imposition sur le revenu je
note cependant qu'une incertitude
demeure quant au cas des missions
temporaires effectuées hors de Suisse
sur le plan social un accord
multilatéral en discussion permettrait
de déroger à la limite des 25%
autorisant jusqu'à 49% de télétravail
c'est un signal prometteur pour des
milliers de frontaliers pour autant la
France n'a toujours pas fait part de ses
attentes quant à sa volonté de rejoindre
ou non cet accord en conséquence
monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous nous
dire quelles sont les intentions de la
France quant à la signature de cet
accord et plus largement pourriez-vous
rassurer nos concitoyens sur l'évolution
des règles de télétravail applicables à
partir du 30 juin 2023 merci pour vous
répondre la parole est communiste du
travail le pénurie monsieur du stop
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs
sur la question des travailleurs
frontaliers et vous savez aussi qu'avant
la crise covid en application du
règlement 883 relatif à la coordination
des règlements de sécurité sociale des
pays de des pays de l'Union européenne
et de la Suisse s'appliquer la règle
suivante le télétravail était limité à
un jour par semaine pour les
travailleurs frontaliers et les
travailleurs frontaliers qui
travaillaient plus d'un jour par semaine
en télétravail basculer dans leur régime
dans le régime social de leur État de
résidence plutôt qu'être maintenu dans
le régime social de leur état employeur
avec la crise covid des souplesse sont
évidemment été apportées en matière
fiscale et en matière sociale et nous
avons prolongé ces accords dérogatoires
jusqu'au 30 juin 2022 en 2022 un groupe
de travail a été mis en place pour
rédiger un accord multilatéral et ce
groupe avait recommandé que la période
de souplesse va prolongée jusqu'au 30
juin 2023 dans maintenant quelques jours
l'accord multilatérale a été rédigé la
France l'examine avec attention avec
attention et avec un regret le regret
que les règles en matière d'assurance
chômage n'est pas été intégré dans cet
accord multilatéral relatif au
télétravail c'est d'ailleurs un regret
qui fait écho à d'autres discussions
puisque le règlement 883-2 coordination
des règlements de sécurité sociale au
niveau européen que j'ai évoqué fait
l'objet aujourd'hui d'une tentative de
révision et sur les différents chapitres
qui font cet accord le chapitre de
l'assurance chômage et notamment de
l'exportation des droits en matière
d'assurance chômage pour les
travailleurs frontaliers reste un
chapitre en débat nous regardons cela
avec attention évidemment avec la
volonté de faire valoir les intérêts de
la France et de notre système de
protection sociale nous le faisons avec
Madame le Premier ministre en entendant
aussi le besoin de sécurisation et
d'accompagnement de nouvelles modalités
de travail que connaissent aujourd'hui
les frontaliers qui comme l'ensemble des
salariés connaissent un développement du
télétravail plus important que ça n'a
jamais été le cas d'ici au 30 juin donc
dans quelques heures maintenant les
décisions seront rendues publiques avec
ce double objectif accompagner nos
frontaliers et dans le même temps faire
valoir les intérêts de notre pays
merci la parole est au président Patrick
canaire pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste les républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre
hier matin à Nanterre Naël 17 ans a été
tué à bout portant par un membre des
forces de l'ordre
nous ne connaissons pas encore les
circonstances exactes de ce drame mais
les images sont terribles la lumière
doit être faites car un refus
d'obtempérer ne peut ne doit se terminer
par la mort d'un jeune
nos premiers mots vont naturellement à
la famille de la victime et à sa maman
toute mort est tragique mais quand la
victime a 17 ans et que les
circonstances sont celles que l'on
connaît on peine à imaginer la
souffrance des proches le temps du deuil
doit être respecté
aussi les violences et dégradations
qu'on a pu constater hier à Nanterre et
dans d'autres villes françaises doivent
être condamnés elles le seront jamais la
solution et nous joignons aux demandes
de Patrick Jarry maire de Nanterre nous
voulons comprendre et nous appelons à la
retenue les enquêtes administratives et
judiciaires de aboutir vite à la
manifestation de la vérité conditions du
retour au calme mais ce n'est pas
suffisant
dans le tel circonstances chacun doit
être à la hauteur de ses responsabilités
je dénonce les tweets incendiaires de
certains syndicats de policiers
minoritaires certes mais néanmoins
intolérable vous l'entendrez jamais de
surenchir dans nos paroles madame
famille ministre nous croyons à la
police de la République mais lorsqu'un
drame comme celui d'hier se produit
c'est l'exemplarité de l'État de droit
qui est interrogé et c'est aussi son
autorité qui est potentiellement
fragilisée en conséquence il faut
objectivement évaluer l'application de
l'article 435-1 du code de la sécurité
intérieure sur l'usage des armes et en
tirer les conséquences il faut également
reconsidérer la formation des policiers
et les moyens qui y sont alloués tout au
long de leur carrière avec cette
tragédie au-delà des paroles vos
réponses et vos actes doivent participer
à l'apaisement que le pays attend madame
la Première ministre il y a urgence
pour vous répondre la parole est comme
madame la Première ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
Président Patrick Kanner
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire la mort
d'un adolescent de 17 ans est un drame
épouvantable le président de la
République a dit tout à l'heure la peine
et l'émotion de la nation à mon tour à
nouveau avec tout mon gouvernement je
veux adresser mes condoléances à la
famille et au proche de Naël et leur
dire toute ma solidarité la justice est
saisie elle avance l'auteur du coup de
feu est en garde à vue et je souhaite
comme chacun que la vérité puisse être
faite au plus vite alors vous
m'interrogez spécifiquement sur nos
règles et sur la formation de nos forces
de l'ordre
vous connaissez tout comme moi monsieur
le Président Kanner leur engagement au
quotidien
policier et gendarmes connaissent leur
devoirs d'exemplarité et comme nous
l'avons toujours dit quand il y a des
fautes les fonctionnaires ont à en
répondre tant au plan administratif que
judiciaire
les images particulièrement choquantes
du contrôle de Naël donne ta pensée que
le cadre d'intervention légale n'a pas
été respecté mais seul la justice le
dira et nous en tirons évidemment toutes
les conséquences et dans l'immédiat le
ministre de l'Intérieur prendra les
décisions qui s'imposent à l'issue de la
garde à vue
monsieur le Président canner le réto
deuil à l'enquête et à l'apaisement nous
avons une exigence absolue de vérité
c'est elle qui nous permettra de
surmonter les colères et de donner les
réponses qu'attendent légitimement la
famille de Naël les élus et les Français
je vous remercie
merci
quelques secondes monsieur le président
merci président pour votre générosité
madame la famille ministre beaucoup
d'entre nous sont d'anciens élus
responsables des lieux nationaux et nous
avons même été parfois ministre en
charge des politiques de la ville et
nous savons que la vérité et la justice
sont l'outil du meilleur apaisement dans
nos quartiers merci pour votre
mobilisation mais nous attendons
beaucoup de vos actes dans la matière
la parole est à notre collègue Christian
BIAC pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre mesdames les ministres
monsieur les ministres ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur mitre
et le pouvoir d'achat des Français en
est fortement impacté même chez le recul
le retour à un niveau de prix d'avoir
une guerre à l'Ukraine est-il une joie
nos compatriotes sont confrontés à une
forte hausse des prix d'un des secteurs
de première nécessité et la précarité
alimentaire s'installe comme en témoigne
les associations dès l'urgence qui ont
accueilli 22% de bénéficiaires en plus
depuis un homme
parallèlement à l'heure de la
réindustrialisation de la France toutes
les entreprises ont des difficultés pour
recruter et il a de même dans le
chercheur public dans l'éducation
nationale dans la justice dans les
hôpitaux dans l'armée dans la police ou
la gendarmerie et dans les collectivités
territoriales les candidatures ne sont
pas chez nombreuses et les postes
ouverts au concours de son pas pourvu
en réponse le gouvernement a privilégié
la politique du chèque de la prime ou
encore du bouquet tarifaire les salariés
ne veulent pas de chaque distribué comme
une au monde ou encore comme la pièce
comme donner ma grand-mère quand j'étais
petit le samedi ils veulent tout
simplement un salaire leur permettant de
vivre correctement
la politique des primes entre chaque
pouvait se comprendre durant la crise
sanitaire mais cette réponse est
désormais adaptée si cela donne un coup
de pouce momentané au pouvoir d'achat le
fait de notre passe où j'étais au côté
de la chose sociale fera que les
travailleurs pauvres d'aujourd'hui
seront des retraités très pauvres de
demain c'est pourquoi je vous demande si
vous envisagez d'index chez les salaires
sur les prix afin que la perte de
pouvoir d'achat des salariés et de
retraités ne continuent pas de
s'aggraver
pour vous répondre la parole est la
madame la ministre déléguée en charge
des petites moyennes entreprises du
commerce madame Olivia Grégoire vous
avez la parole madame la ministre
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur bilak
le gouvernement depuis maintenant deux
ans est aux côtés des concitoyens
français des salariés et les soutiens
pas uniquement avec des chèques pour me
référer très précisément à votre
question mais aussi avec des mesures
importantes comme le bouclier tarifaire
vous l'avez mentionné mais aussi depuis
six mois désormais avec Bruno Le Maire à
vos avec Roland Lescure en incitant sans
faire de chèques à la fois les acteurs
de la grande distribution mais aussi les
acteurs des de l'industrie
agroalimentaire à renégocier et à
baisser les prix la réalité c'est que
les prix sont en train de baisser vous
l'avez mentionné je rappelle quand même
que pour la première fois depuis
septembre 2021 l'inflation alimentaire a
baissé nous étions à 14.9 en mai
alors que nous étions à 15.8 en avril
les baisses de prix sont en train d'être
discutées vous parlez de produits
première nécessité des renégociations
sont en cours en ce moment même nous
l'avons demandé avec Bruno Le Maire au
75 plus gros industriels de
l'agroalimentaire dès le premier juillet
très concrètement dans les rayons les
grandes surfaces notamment un certain
nombre de produits vont baisser
visiblement je pense à l'huile de
tournesol je pense aux pattes mais je
pense aussi par exemple à la volaille je
pense aussi à un certain nombre de
produits de snacking je pense au
vinaigre je pense au thé je ne vais pas
vous faire toute la logorrhée mais les
prix sont en train de baisser certains
continuent à augmenter il faut être très
lucide certains cours de matières
premières continuent à être élevés je
pense au sucre je pense au port je pense
à la charcuterie donc il y aura des
baisses de prix et d'autres prix qui ne
baisseront pas immédiatement pour ce qui
est de votre suggestion d'indexer les
salaires sur l'inflation
il y a un pays voisin qui l'a fait c'est
la Belgique
ce pays a des taux d'inflation
extrêmement élevés ce pays voit des
salariés qui se battent pour aussi payer
leurs courses mais surtout qui sont
battus tout l'hiver pour payer leur
facture d'électricité ça n'est
malheureusement pas la solution possible
dans tous les pays ça n'est pas la
solution que nous avons choisi elle
n'est pas à notre sens la plus efficace
pour les protéger merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur
je suis heureux d'apprendre que les prix
n'augmentent plus c'est parce que disent
les gens que je rencontre c'est pas ce
que je constate quand je vais faire mes
courses et puis je crois que il faut
quand même arrêter de montrer du doigt
les salariés les gens qui se lèvent le
matin pour travailler on leur a mis deux
ans de retraite de plus hier encore les
montrer du doigt pour les arrêts de
travail mais quand il fait ces gens qui
se lèvent le matin pour travailler je me
le demande
merci
la parole est notre collègue Thomas
dessus pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité territoire vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur un
jeune homme de 17 ans est mort hier
Naël a été abattu par un agent de police
à bout portant aujourd'hui au nom du
groupe écologiste j'adresse penser et
condoléances à sa mère sa famille et ses
amis aujourd'hui après une nuit de
colère dans certaines villes de France
notre rôle doit être d'appeler au calme
au nom du respect pour le temps du
recueillement à la mémoire de Naël au
nom du respect de la justice et de la
vérité ce matin face aux images le
président de la République a parlé d'un
acte inexcusable et inexplicable
inexcusable sans aucun doute
inexplicable certainement pas oui il y a
des raisons qui ont conduit à ce drame
nous nous souvenons ici des efforts que
vous avez déployés monsieur le ministre
au combat dans cette hémicycle toutes
les propositions visant à améliorer les
rapports entre la police et la
population fidèle à votre doctrine 100%
répressive nous nous souvenons votre
acharnement à vouloir interdire de
filmer l'action de la police et nous
voyons comment depuis des années drame
après drame avec détermination vous
défendez la honteuse loi Cazeneuve qui
permet à la police d'ouvrir le feu sur
les chauffeurs d'une voiture selon des
conditions manifestement trop floues
depuis cette loi 40% des tirs sur des
véhicules en plus par rapport aux 5
années la précédente l'an dernier 13
décès ont été enregistrés après des
refuses tempérés lors des contrôles
routiers un record un triste record
cette loi est manifestement trop laxiste
et la manifestement permis le
développement d'un sentiment d'impunité
qui hier a conduit à un drame monsieur
le ministre si vous voulez que le calme
revienne et nous l'appelons de nos vœux
il est temps de revenir sur cette loi
combien de morts supplémentaires
faudra-t-il pour que vous en preniez
conscience
on vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'intérieur des Outre-mer
monsieur Gérald Darmanin
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
j'ai eu l'occasion
comme l'a fait à l'instant madame la
Première ministre comme l'a fait
président de la République te dire
évidemment tout le drame que nous
inspire ce qui s'est passé hier à
Nanterre que la justice doit très vite
apporter des réponses et que des
sanctions seront prises contre un
policier qui manifestement d'après les
images extrêmement choquantes que nous
avons vu et bien sûr des premiers
éléments de l'enquête qui ont qui sont
sortis de la presse manifestement pas
été conforme monsieur le sénateur à la
législation et à la déontologie à la
formation de la police nationale mais je
crois monsieur qu'en toute chose en tout
temps il faut avoir de la dignité je
crois que la récupération politique au
moment où une famille pleure son enfant
au moment où des écoles ont été
attaquées hier au moment au 24 policiers
ont été blessés ont partout en France il
peut y avoir une légitime émotion et un
énervement qui évidemment ne peut être
accepté sur les règles de la République
il ne peut pas y avoir de récupération
politique
vous avez monsieur sénateur fait un
drôle de parallèle celui désormais de
vouloir que nous légions sous l'émotion
finalement et vous avez monsieur le
sénateur profité c'est affreux de ce
terrible drame pour appeler votre
opposition à la loi qui avait prise de
président Hollande et le Premier
ministre Cazeneuve dans des temps
différents puisque c'était des temps je
le rappelle d'attentat terroriste qui
prévoit dans l'article que vous évoquez
non pas que des policiers ou des
gendarmes puissent tirer sur une voiture
c'est totalement faux et c'est fou de le
dire dans cette hémicycle aux yeux des
Français monsieur setter fait que dans
certaines circonstances lorsque les
policiers sont eux-mêmes en danger de
mort qu'ils puissent utiliser leur arme
est-ce que ce policier était en danger
de mort pour utiliser son arme c'est ce
que montrera l'enquête judiciaire a
priori des images qu'on a tous vu de son
choquantes parce que ça ne correspond
pas à la loi 2017 loi 2007 que je ne
veux pas ici particulièrement justifié
devant vous n'ayant pas été son auteur
mais surtout trouvant que c'est le temps
du deuil du recueillement et la dignité
républicaine et non la récupération
politique
[Applaudissements]
mais
monsieur
monsieur le ministre il n'y aura pas de
paix sans vérité il n'y aura pas de
justice sans vérité et la vérité c'est
que vous continuez de soutenir cette loi
c'est toi qui a conduit à ce drame
la vérité c'est que cette loi va en
provoquer d'autres je vous remercie
[Musique]
la parole est à notre collègue Danny
watteled pour le groupe Les Indépendants
République et territoire
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre le sport doit toujours
contribuer à la cohésion de notre
société il permet à chacun et à chacune
de se réaliser dans l'effort quel que
soit son origine et ça lui tient social
j'ai toujours défendu cette valeur une
universaliste du sport hier comme local
aujourd'hui comme sénateur nous sommes
nombreux ici à récif fidèle à l'esprit
de Pierre de Coubertin à moins d'un an
des Jeux olympiques de Paris il me
paraît essentiel de rappeler le
caractère universel des valeurs du sport
car elles sont de plus en plus
contestées dans notre pays
le collectif des abuse revendique ainsi
le droit de participer à des
compétitions officielles de football en
portant le foulard islamique alors qu'en
Iran des femmes risquent leur vie pour
vivre sans le voile en France certaines
se battent pour pouvoir l'imposer sur
les terrains de football
ont attaqué l'article premier des
statuts de la fédération française de
football qui interdit tout port de
signes ou tenues manifestement au
sensiblement une appartenance politique
philosophique religieuse ou syndicale
lundi il aura peut-être à donner un avis
favorable à leur revendication plutôt
que permettre une revendication
religieuse sur un terrain de football il
est essentiel de préserver le sport de
tous séparatisme c'est le sens de la
position de loi que j'ai faite le 25 mai
du 22 soyons lucides les islamiques
s'engouffent dans toutes les portes
ouvertes et le sport en est une madame
la ministre je ne vous demande pas de
commenter une décision de cash-6 n'a pas
encore rendu cependant le gourmand
est-il prêt à légiférer pour clarifier
notre droit si nécessaire et garantir la
neutralité religieuse dans le sport
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Madame la Ministre des Sports des Jeux
Olympiques paralympiques madame oudia
castérale vous avez la parole monsieur
[Musique]
le président monsieur le sénateur va te
blettes je vous remercie de ne pas me
demander de commenter une affaire
juridictionnelle qui est en délibérée
les séances d'État travaillé jusqu'au
bout dans le respect de son impartialité
de son indépendance et ce d'autant que
je le rappelle que la formation de
jugement n'est pas tenue par les
conclusions du rapporteur public cette
décision elle sera rendue demain on va
en analyser le sens la portée les
justifications et voir si nécessaire
s'il y a besoin de prendre une
initiative politique si oui de quel type
et avec quel support dans cette attente
ce que je veux faire c'est rappeler
notre double boussole la défense de
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
et la préservation de la laïcité dans le
sport ce qui veut dire un assurer la
neutralité du service public y compris
au cœur de nos équipes de France deux
préserver la liberté de conscience qui
est une liberté de croire et de ne pas
croire et donc la nécessité
troisièmement de lutter fermement contre
toutes les formes de séparatisme et de
prosélytisme dans le sport pour ça on a
un outil le contrat d'engagement
républicain pour nous renforçons nos
moyens d'intervention d'enquête pour ça
nous diligentons des contrôles 3500 déjà
sur l'année 2022 pour ça nous
accompagnons les éducateurs les
formateurs les fédérations pour que les
signalements puissent remonter plus vite
et que notre combat soit plus efficace
que jamais contre toutes ces formes de
dérive inacceptables vous le voyez nous
sommes aux côtés des clubs du mouvement
sportif pour faire respecter notre
modèle républicain notre modèle sportif
et lutter contre toutes celles et ceux
qui voudraient y porter atteinte
préserver ce pacte républicain au cœur
du sport voilà notre détermination la
plus absolue
sachez qu'ici au Sénat nous sommes prêts
à légiférer contre ces signes religieux
dans le sport et garder le principe de
laïcité
je donne la parole à notre collègue
Michel Savin pour le groupe les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre le ce lundi le rapporteur
public du Conseil d'État s'est prononcé
donc pour l'annulation de l'article
premier des statues de la Fédération
française de football qui interdit tout
port de signe religieux lors des
compétitions sportives à la suite d'un
recours porté par les jabus et
l'Alliance citoyenne un collectif qui
instrumentalise régulièrement nos
institutions et nos principes
républicains sans préjugés de la vie du
Conseil d'État nous tenions à vous faire
part de notre vie inquiétude quant à
cette attaque du pack républicain mais
aujourd'hui nous n'en serions pas là si
votre gouvernement ne s'était pas opposé
à notre proposition d'interdiction du
port de si nous religieux lors des
compétitions sportives organisées par
des fédérations sportives et les
associations affiliées à plusieurs
reprises notre majorité a adopté cette
proposition en 2020 en 2021 comme en
2022 pendant l'examen des textes
confortant les valeurs de la République
au sud ou celui visant à démocratiser le
sport en France à chaque fois votre
gouvernement si votre majorité l'ont
rejeté par ce refus de soutenir notre
initiative vous avez ouvert la porte à
ses dérives communautaires madame la
ministre assumez-vous cette faute
politique et êtes-vous favorable à
mettre en débat et soutenir la
proposition de loi sur ce sujet que nous
avons redéposé en début d'année par
ailleurs quelle action madame la mélise
comptez-vous avoir vis-à-vis de ces
associations qui compromettent notre
pack crépublicain
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Madame la Ministre des Sports
vous avez la parole
monsieur le sénateur mesdames monsieur
le Président pardon mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Savin je voudrais évidemment un
nouveau rappeler le principe le respect
du pardon Michel est là à la séparation
des pouvoirs que je viens d'évoquer
compte tenu de l'affaire
juridictionnelle qui est en délibéré moi
ce que je veux vous dire c'est notre
détermination avec la première ministre
avec l'ensemble de ce gouvernement de
lutter pour préserver la laïcité dans le
sport comme elle l'a rappelé hier nous
sommes et resterons intransigeants sur
le respect de la neutralité du service
public dans le sport jusqu'au cœur de
nos équipes de France nous serons
intransigeants sur la lutte contre
toutes les formes de prosélytisme et de
radicalisme nous serons également
déterminés en faveur de la défense de
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
je crois que sur tous ces points
monsieur le sénateur nous regardons dans
la même direction la question que vous
posez elle est légitime mais
permettez-moi de vous dire qu'elle est
prématurée nous allons regarder cette
décision nous allons l'analyser regarder
les considérants les motivations et
toutes les conclusions que nous devons
en tirer sans rien exclure vous rappelez
les initiatives que vous avez portées
par le passé nous avons évidemment
étudié avec attention mais je veux
rappeler qu'elle n'était pas toujours
présentée sur le bon support juridique
et d'autres pas qu'elle n'était pas
toujours entourées de toutes les
garanties rendu nécessaire par le
respect de notre Constitution la laïcité
est au cœur du pacte républicain il faut
donc un socle républicain pour la soirée
elle aussi on va donc regarder jusqu'au
bout cette décision et
identifier les espaces qu'elle rend
nécessaire ou non pour l'action
politique et avec quels instrument ce
contexte j'en suis convaincu est une
opportunité pour clarifier pour
réaffirmer notre cadre d'action avec les
bons éclairages juridiques autour de
nous et pour préserver jusqu'au bout la
laïcité dans le sport et donner aux
fédérations le contexte clair et le plus
homogène possible qu'elles attendent
nous le leur devons et elles le
souhaitent monsieur le sénateur je ne
laisserai aucune dérive en tâcher notre
sport et je sais pouvoir agir en ce sens
avec vous ainsi qu'avec tous les
parlementaires qui sont attachés au
pacte républicain je vous remercie
monsieur ça va
madame la ministre stop stop à
l'hypocrisie au manque de courage
politique de ce gouvernement et face à
la radicalisation de certaines
organisations et la multiplication de
ces dérives religieuses si le Conseil
d'État suit la vie du rapporteur public
ne soyons pas naïf sur la suite radioa
par une victoire pour celle qui souhaite
fragiliser avec cette offensive
religieuse un des piliers de notre
société et se traduira par la même par
une défaite politique pour notre
République la réponse du gouvernement ne
peut pas se limiter à des contrôles ou à
des signatures de partenariat avec des
fédérations les toits doit mettre fin à
cette spirale communautaire qui est à
l'opposé des valeurs du sport et de la
République madame la ministre soutenez
notre proposition de loi
merci
la parole est à notre collègue Christine
erdog pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
monsieur le président madame la Première
ministre mes chers collègues j'associe à
ma question ma collègue Sylvie
vermeinier sénatrice du Jura en 2018 la
SNCF a suspendu la liaison directe Metz
Nancy Lyon en raison des travaux
réalisés à Lyon Part-Dieu qui empêchait
son maintien ses travaux devaient durer
quatre ans quatre ans pendant lesquels
la patience des usagers de ce TGV a été
mise à rude épreuve à l'issue des
travaux de la SNCF s'étaient engagé à
repositionner la desserte qui du
Luxembourg à Vintimille permettait aux
usagers de gagner en temps et en
changement
c'était un réel atout pour les quatre
régions des servis du Grand Est à la
PACA en passant par la Bourgogne
Franche-Comté et l'Auvergne Rhône-Alpes
or la SNCF vient de faire savoir qu'elle
annulait finalement cette desserte pour
la renvoyer par tronçon au conseiller
régionaux concerné
à côté de cela elle conseille aux
usagers d'utiliser le TGV Metz
Strasbourg Colmar Dijon celui-là même
qui cible bien plus la clientèle
frontalière que la population française
due au centre des régions or le
contribuable qui soit alsacien ou
Laurent à autant financer la SNCF et
mérite un accès égal au service public
il apparaissent scandaleux que
l'actionnaire majoritaire l'État se
laisse dicter les lois du marché
lucratif de sorte abandonner le service
public et une ligne française historique
dans le même temps l'État et ses
contribuables prennent en charge 35
milliards d'euros de SNCF réseau pour
éponger sa dette
madame la Première ministre comment
pouvez-vous le 24 février dernier
annoncé un grand plan d'investissement
de 100 milliards d'euros à horizon 2040
pour le secteur ferroviaire et 4 mois
plus tard accepter la suppression de
cette ligne indispensable au maillage de
notre territoire je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est
communiste de la transition écologique
et de la cohésion des territoires
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame
la sénatrice Christina
de vous répondre s'il avait été présent
dans cette émission puisque vous savez
l'attention particulière qu'il porte à
ce sujet en quelques mots vous avez
rappelé le cadre ces travaux à Lyon
Part-Dieu 80 interruption et au moment
où la reprise aurait pu s'amorcer la
prise de position de la SNCF disant que
le trafic
escompté ne justifie pas d'y affecter
les matériels qui auparavant
permettaient d'assurer cette desserte
le gouvernement est pas resté inactif le
ministre délégué chargé des Transports a
pris des engagements précis pour que
cette liaisonaisse Lyon qui passe par
Nancy puissent réouvrir mais avec à la
minute où nous nous parlons à la fois
des interrogations sur la cadence et sur
le niveau de service qui ont suscité la
mobilisation des élus de ce territoire
au cours de ces dernières mois et je
sais la sensibilité et la mobilisation
particulière madame la sénatrice Herzog
dont vous avez fait preuve la préfète de
la région Grand Est réuni la SNCF les
services de l'État les élus les
parlementaires intéressés dont vous et
elle le refera à nouveau pour préciser à
la suite des réunions précédentes la
faisabilité technique de ce qui a été
évoqué vous savez qu'on discutons de
l'usage temporaire de TER qui soit issus
de la région Grand Est mais il y a
derrière la question au-delà de ce
temps-là du type de matériel qui
pourrait être affecté et de la date de
livraison de train d'équilibre
territoriaux qui ont été esquissés il y
a des sujets budgétaires il y a des
sujets techniques je termine sur un mot
puisque encore une fois cette réunion
est censée se tenir dans les toutes
prochaines semaines le plan annoncé par
la première ministre il met en lumière
quoi mais en lumière que malheureusement
le sous-investissement pendant des
décennies sur les 29000 km de réseau de
la SNCF notre patrimoine commun on
conduit à ces interruptions à ses
déficits de matériel et c'est bien cette
inversion que nos envisageons avec ce
coi et ses conclusions
merci
la parole est à notre collègue Alexandra
borscio font-ils pour le groupe les
républicain
madame la ministre en France plus de la
moitié des étudiants de première année
de licence échoue dès lors que
pensez-vous de la casse organisée par
parcoursup
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre de l'Enseignement supérieur et
de la Recherche madame Sylvie Retailleau
monsieur le Président merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs les sénatrices madame la
sénatrice c'est une question claire
concise auquel je vais essayer de
répondre aussi clairement dans le temps
qui m'est imparti tout d'abord je
voudrais vous dire que parcoursup c'est
un outil c'est un outil dans lequel nous
sommes et vous êtes probablement très
sollicite en cette période et auquel
nous devons répondre dans son volet
d'orientation et c'est dans lequel nous
travaillons avec le ministre de
l'éducation nationale parce
qu'effectivement la réussite de nos
étudiants liés à la loi du 8 mars 2018
avec des volets d'orientation et la
partie d'orientation donc l'année
prochaine le ministre a décidé de
généraliser l'expérimentation par
exemple de la découverte des métiers au
collège dès la 5ème 3ème en lycée il y a
l'orientation avec les professeurs
principaux en terminale et nous
continuons à travailler bien évidemment
pour donner les ressources nécessaires
pour mieux personnaliser humaniser cette
orientation et permettre aux élèves donc
au futur étudiants de trouver leur voie
leur voix adaptée à eux pour pouvoir
exercer le métier de leur choix et puis
dans le supérieur il y a la loi réussite
et orientation qui a apporté
effectivement des outils des moyens aux
établissements et je vous rejoins le
premier cycle est un enjeu particulier
pour nos établissements nous les y
accompagnons nous les y accompagnons en
regardant les débouchés l'insertion
professionnelle et dans ce sens nous
avons renseigné parcoursup sur la
transparence non seulement des critères
d'examen des vœux c'est important de
savoir mais aussi sur l'orientation les
taux de réussite les taux d'insertion et
nous avons travaillé tous ensemble pour
améliorer mieux accompagner et rendre ce
côté humain d'orientation
d'accompagnement et de réussite je vous
remercie madame la sénatrice
madame Porsche au forty
madame la ministre ma question
s'adressée également bien sûr au
ministre de l'éducation nationale encore
des annonces j'allais dire conjugués au
futur on s'y attendait évidemment le
président de la République on a fait
autant avant-hier à Marseille depuis 5
ans maintenant les étudiants tentent de
trouver des stratégies pour déjouer le
dispositif les enseignants eux aussi
d'ailleurs essayent de donner les moyens
à leurs élèves d'accéder à leurs projets
inflation inouïe de la notation dans le
bulletin scolaire surenchères des
appréciations des enseignants ou le
dithyramb est devenu la règle certains
lycées pratiquent même le double
bulletin c'est à dire une autre vitrine
pour parcoursup et puis une autre
véritable pour informer quand même
l'élève de son niveau réel quant au
système lui-même complexité technique de
la plateforme lettre de motivation non
examinée ou encore critères de sélection
d'une totale opacité parcoursup à
renverser le bac déjà affaibli par le
contrôle continu dont les notes varient
d'un établissement à l'autre par
l'angoisse de l'arbitraire froid de
l'algorithme on a déshumanisé cette
dernière étape de la vie scolaire au nom
d'un impératif technocratique
parcoursupa également désorganiser
l'année terminale les élèves ont cinq
mois désormais pour se préparer aux
épreuves une incongruité supplémentaire
qui accentue l'absentéisme lors du
dernier trimestre c'est juste trois mois
d'apprentissage perdu et puis une
épreuve de philo dévalorisée une
régression pédagogique qui aggrave les
inégalités impactent les chances de
réussite d'une jeunesse sacrifiée sur
l'hôtel de parcoursup Madame la Ministre
le 1er juin est devenu la Journée
nationale de l'angoisse Cesson cette
absurdité bureaucratique pour l'accès au
savoir en tout cas nous sénateurs du
groupe les républicains nous demandons
la création d'un véritable service
public de l'orientation dont le but
n'est pas d'avoir 100% de réussite au
bac mais plutôt d'instruire de bien
former et de mieux orienter cette
ambition éducative est aussi humaniste
servons-nous des outils numériques pour
garantir un processus d'orientation et
pour documenter vos travaux je propose
de suivre les recommandations de notre
rapporteur Jacques gros Perrin
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue de vie d'asuline avant de
d'aller plus loin dans la parole je
voudrais le remercier pour ces années
Sénats et mes chers collègues si vous
avez un écran devant vous et à votre
numérique automatique c'est à David
insuline que vous le devez dans sa
période de vice-président du Sénat voilà
merci monsieur le Président mais chers
collègues monsieur le ministre au moment
de ma dernière mon groupe que je salue
m'a fait l'honneur de me confier une
question qui fut au coeur de mon
engagement de mes plaidoiries de mes
travaux avec vous dans cette émission
depuis de nombreuses années
l'indépendance le plus réalise et la
liberté des médias je veux vous dire
notre inquiétude car on concentration
économique qui monopolise les médias
entre quelques groupes industriels et
financiers dont l'activité principale
est le plus souvent étrangère à la
presse à l'information ou à la culture
se construit devant nous un empire
médiatique de propagande au service
d'une idéologie qui promeule la haine de
l'autre
en effet Monsieur Bolloré qui est en son
empire à la télé à la radio à la presse
écrite au cinéma et à l'édition
qui en contrôle presque la totalité y
compris la majorité des livres scolaires
détruit des rédactions entières comme à
iTélé aura pas par image et maintenant
le JDD en lui imposant contre son avis
exprimé à 98% par les journalistes un
directeur renvoyé d'un journal d'extrême
droite parce qu'il était lui-même trop
d'extrême droite monsieur le ministre
vous ne pouvez pas nous dire qu'on ne
peut rien faire car la situation est
grave on peut mieux protéger
l'indépendance des rédactions en leur
permettant de valider à une majorité
qualifiée leur directeur proposé par
l'actionnaire et les états généraux de
la formation promis par le Président de
la République c'est pour quand
on veut répondre la parole est terminée
chargée du renouveau démocratique
Monsieur Olivier Véran
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur David Assouline à mon tour et
au nom du gouvernement je voudrais
saluer votre action comme sénateur
toutes ces années et l'apport qui aura
été le vôtre dans cette Haute Assemblée
monsieur le sénateur vous interrogez le
gouvernement sur la question du rachat
enfin pas du rachat pardonnez-moi de la
nomination Geoffre le jeune à la tête du
JDD comme vous êtes un très fin
connaisseur des règles dans le milieu
culturel vous savez qui ne revient pas
au gouvernement de décider qui va
diriger telle ou tel journal évidemment
et d'ailleurs si c'était le cas ce
serait grave je pense qu'il y aurait
uneanimité sur ces bancs pour considérer
que nous outre passerions nos droits
l'État est là pour garantir le
pluralisme et la liberté de la presse il
est là aussi pour financer plus de 400
titres de presse ont été subventionnés
l'année dernière et c'est très bien
ainsi ils n'empêche pas qu'il qu'on peut
se poser la question on peut se poser la
question de savoir s'il ne faut pas
mettre à l'abri je dirais des comités de
rédaction de l'influence actionnaire
c'est une question qui est légitime vous
soulignez par exemple la possibilité de
soumettre au suffrage des rédacteurs des
journalistes
quotidien ou d'un autre journal le vote
pour désigner le rédacteur en chef je
sais que certains journaux le font comme
par exemple les échos moi j'ai envie de
vous dire Monsieur le Sénateur il va y
avoir d'abord il y a une réflexion qui a
commencé au Parlement sous l'égide de la
ministre de la Culture dont j'excuse
l'absence d'ailleurs parce qu'elle est
avec le président de la République à
Marseille et les parlementaire ont aussi
pour objectif de regarder la loi blog de
2016 pour voir ce qui pourrait être
éventuellement renforcé améliorer ou
modifier dans ce cadre-là par ailleurs
vous l'avez dit vous-même le président
de la République souhaite organiser des
états généraux de l'information qui
pourrait être pourquoi pas une
opportunité pour aborder ce type de
problématique il ne me revient pas de
vous dire que c'est précisément ce type
de problématique que nous aborderons
mais dès lors qu'on ouvre ce chantier
qui est important et bien on pourra se
poser toutes les questions qui qui
conviennent donc voilà monsieur le
sénateur j'espère avoir répondu non pas
sur le cas précis qui vous occupe et qui
vous mobilise mais sur le cas général de
l'indépendance du pluralisme et de la
liberté de la presse
tu as souligne
j'ai posé cette question sans esprit
polémique je pense qu'il faut un sursaut
j'en appelle à tout mes collègues sur
les bancs dans un monde où toutes les
démocraties sont menacées où les
populismes centrés ont fait l'enjeu de
la liberté de la presse et vitale c'est
un enjeu républicain qui doit nous
rassembler c'est un enjeu démocratique
qui doit nous mobiliser je vous demande
de méditer cette phrase de Victor Hugo
la liberté de la presse à côté du
suffrage universel c'est la pensée de
tous éclairant le gouvernement de tous a
tenté à l'une c'est à tenter à l'autre
la parole
est à notre collègue Laurence saumon
pour le groupe les républicains
madame la Première ministre Pierre Dac
disait il faut une infinie patience pour
attendre toujours ce qui n'arrive jamais
à l'étude depuis 1990 en état de mort
clinique en 2016 malgré un débat public
qui a conclu à l'excellente rentabilité
socio-économique du dossier réanimer en
mars 2017 et promis par le Premier
ministre Bernard Cazeneuve dans le cadre
du plan de revitalisation de laminoir le
barreau TGV Creil Roissy était
formellement acté par un courrier du
président de la République le 12 août
2019 adressé à Madame le maire d'Amiens
après que vous-même madame la Première
ministre l'ayez annoncé en avril 2019
lors d'une visite dans la capitale
picarde le courrier précisé en outre le
calendrier et sa mise en service en 2025
annoncé à 310 millions et arrivé à 580
millions d'euros aujourd'hui le plan de
financement a été bouclé avec une
participation de 51% de l'État
l'adjonction des collectivités locales
Région Département EPCI est communes le
coût marginal devait être couvert par
une participation de européenne à
hauteur de 80 millions d'euros jeudi
nous apprenions le rejet de cette
demande présentée à deux reprises à
l'Union européenne je reprendrai donc
les propos du président de l'Association
des maires de France au sujet des
défaillances successives
états-tu que fais-tu plus précisément
madame la première Mini je vous demande
premièrement peut-on encore avoir
confiance dans la parole du président de
la République de les engagements écrits
des gouvernements sont-ils encore
crédibles et l'État a-t-il le pouvoir de
contraindre la volonté réfractaire de
SNCF réseau pour que soit mis les moyens
engager les travaux et respecter le
calendrier et enfin surtout la France
a-t-elle encore une présence efficace et
une influence réelle au sein de l'Union
européenne et suppléez-vous et
supplierez-vous ces financements
manquants
alors pour vous répondre
la parole est communiste transit de la
cohésion des territoires monsieur Béchu
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur saumon il est singulier de
pointer la responsabilité du Président
de la République alors que vous avez
précisément indiqué ce qui était le
point de départ des inquiétudes
légitimes de la somme des hauts trans de
manière générale après les prises de
parole très fortes en particulier du
président Xavier Bertrand il y a
quelques jours le 22 juin la Commission
a attribué au projet français une note
de 19 sur 25 mais qui ne nous a pas
permis d'obtenir de financement avec un
point positif qui est la reconnaissance
européenne du projet et dans les points
négatifs le fait de constater qu'il y
avait un certain nombre d'autorisations
de précision qui devaient être apportées
ce chemin là il dessine la possibilité
pour nous de redéposer une demande avant
le 1er janvier 2024 de boucler le
dossier de financement en fonction de ça
au mois d'octobre et de pouvoir
envisager un démarrage de travaux en
2024 pour une mise en service en 2025
là encore a eu le président Bertrand au
téléphone il a redit dimanche que non
seulement ça ne modifiait pas le soutien
du gouvernement français à ce projet
mais que notre engagement réalisé ces 6
km et demi dont vous l'avez dit
l'ensemble des conditions
socio-économiques ont y compris été
pointé comme étant favorable par la
Commission européenne renforce notre
détermination dans ce contexte je
considère que ce refus de la Commission
européenne il doit pas nous conduire à
nous diviser entre nous aller chercher
ses crédits européens pour obtenir le
complément du financement c'est la
priorité absolue si d'aventure nous ne
les avions pas on entrerait dans autre
chose mais partir du principe que nous
n'aurions pas cet argent alors que le
projet est reconnu comme étant d'intérêt
européen je pense que ce serait
collectivement nous affaiblir dans un
contexte de négociation ou au contraire
on doit être soudé vous exprimez
l'exaspération le ras-le-bol et la tente
des territoires vous rappelez la date de
2025 je ne fais pas autre chose je vous
demande qu'on monte à bord dans cette
bataille nouvelle devant la Commission
européenne et je vous redis ce projet
nous le ferons
monsieur
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre vous avez
effectivement rappelé les propos du
ministre qui rappelaient dimanche Creil
Roissy est un projet qui avance et se
fera malheureusement on avance à la
vitesse de la draisine on peut craindre
de vivre les propos de Marcel Proust à
savoir qu'on a plus rien à espérer
n'empêche pas de continuer à attendre
alors même en perte de vitesse sur le
réseau européen respectez vos
engagements accélérer pour que la France
retrouve sa locomotive et à la vitesse
du TGV permettait comme la promue le
président de la République que les
trains ont conclu en temps et en heure à
sa ville natale
la parole est à notre collègue François
Baudot pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
mais c'est le président madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
des Affaires étrangères
les récents événements impliquant le
groupe islamiste paramilitaire pardon
Wagner ne manqueront pas d'avoir des
conséquences en Afrique le groupe est
présent au Soudan en République
centrafricaine en Libye au Mali et au
Mozambique
Wagner est devenu un outil important de
la lutte d'influence russes en Afrique
développant un panel d'activités allant
de la protection des États à
l'exploitation des ressources naturelles
en passant par les opérations
d'information et surtout de
désinformation à la fois antioxydantal
essentiellement anti française
cependant la rupture entre Wagner et le
Kremlin a de fortes chances de
déstabiliser les opérations de Wagner en
Afrique de l'Ouest
en tant que paria soumis à la vindique
de ces commanditaires russes Wagner et
son dirigeant Afghani privé dans une
position instable et délicate
les activités brutales et sanglantes de
Wagner sont largement financés par
l'exploitation illégitime des ressources
naturelles c'est pourquoi les États-Unis
ont annoncé hier de nouvelles sanctions
contre les activités de Wagner visant à
empêcher son expansion en Afrique
dans ce contexte il est crucial que la
France agisse de manière énergique en
intensifiant sa coopération avec nos
partenaires africains notamment dans le
Golf de Guinée très inquiet à la fois de
la contagion terroriste mais aussi des
milices incontrôlables madame la
ministre quelles conséquence vos
circuits anticipent-ils en Afrique à la
suite de la rupture de banc du groupe
Wagner et comment la France
entend-t-elle réagir pour soutenir nos
partenaires africains et protéger les
intérêts de cette région éminemment
stratégique
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre déléguer en charge des Français
de l'étranger et du commerce extérieur
monsieur belge
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur François Bonnot
d'abord je vous prie d'excuser l'absence
de la ministre de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères qui m'a chargé de
vous répondre il faut dire les choses
telles qu'elles sont Wagner ce n'est pas
une société militaire privée ce n'est
pas une milice c'est un groupe criminel
et mafieux qui en a les méthodes la
violence la prédation la manipulation
les règlements de comptes un groupe sur
lequel la Russie s'appuie pour mener les
actions qu'elle n'est pas capable de
conduire avec son armée régulière Wagner
a établi partout au lycée déployé la
violation systématique des droits de
l'homme en principe cardinal de son
action
celle-ci a systématiquement renforcé la
menace terroriste qu'il prétendait
combattre que ce soit en Syrie en Libye
homosambique au Mali ou en République de
Centrafrique Wagner est un véritable
fléau dont le seul objectif est de
piller les richesses au détriment des
États et des populations et au prix
d'exaction atroces j'en veux pour preuve
le rapport accablant des Nations Unies
qui établit clairement la responsabilité
du groupe Wagner dans le massacre de 500
civils à Moura au Mali en mars 2022
nous ne laisserons aucun espace à cette
organisation qui n'hésite pas à recruter
parmi les criminels les plus endurci
dans les prisons russes et pour répondre
concrètement à votre question oui nous
continuerons à imposer des sanctions
européennes rigoureuses pour ces actions
en Ukraine comme en Afrique et nous
disons au pays qui ont fait le choix de
Wagner et qui peut-être d'ailleurs le
regrette en voyant les événements de ce
week-end qu'il est temps de s'en
dissocier car rien de bon ne peut sortir
du chaos dont Wagner s'est fait une
spécialité je vous remercie monsieur
Bono
vous avez quelques secondes
oui monsieur ministre effectivement la
Russie poutinienne n'a cessé de
fustiger nos démocratie
occidentales force cette constater que
c'est au contraire la dictature russe
qui pourrie de l'Intérieur agissons
fermement pour regagner les positions
que nous avons perdu
merci
la parole est à notre collègue Guillaume
chevrolier pour le groupe les
républicains
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse le
ministre de la Fonction publique
l'année passée l'apprentissage a atteint
un niveau record plus de 800 000
contrats signés c'est une bonne nouvelle
cependant ce qui concerne la fonction
publique territoriale beaucoup de nos
communes rurales nous alertent sur leurs
difficultés à recruter les candidats
sont nombreux mais les financements ne
suivent pas pour l'année 2023 18000
intentions de recrutement des
collectivités ont été recensés alors
même que le budget prévu ne permet d'en
financer que 10 000 en mars dernier la
circulaire relative renforcement du
recrutement d'apprentis dans la fonction
publique précisait que les objectifs
d'embauche
et annonçaient la baisse progressive de
la participation de France compétences
au frais de formation en apprentissage à
hauteur de 15 millions d'euros
aujourd'hui elle s'élèvera seulement 5
millions d'euros pour 2025 et rien n'est
prévu pour compenser cette diminution
par la suite
les mers et l'ensemble des élus
s'enquête vivement ainsi que les centres
de formation comme les Maisons
Familiales Rurales ce n'est pas la faute
d'avoir alerté le gouvernement à ce
sujet lors des débats sur le projet de
loi de finances pourtant madame la
Première ministre a déclaré à ton un
engagement fort des employeurs publics
espérant dépasser prochainement le
million d'apprentis hors forcer de
constater qu'un décalage subsiste entre
l'ambition affichée et les moyens
alloués à terme ainsi que la complexité
du cadre juridique même le Centre
national de la fonction publique
territoriale insiste régulièrement sur
l'insuffisance des financements par
rapport aux besoins alors monsieur le
ministre le gouvernement compte-t-il
revoir ses objectifs en matière
d'apprentissage et réévaluer les moyens
financiers à la hauteur des besoins des
collectivités locales
pour vous répondre la parole deobilise
la transformation de la fonction
publique chez Guerini
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Chevrolet je veux dire trois
choses pour répondre à votre question la
première c'est un satisfait site
collectif nous avons fait dans la
fonction publique ces dernières années
la révolution de l'apprentissage faut se
dire les choses telles qu'elles sont il
y a quelques années il n'y avait pas
d'apprenti dans la fonction publique et
collectivité hôpitaux administration
concentré ou déconcentré ça marche nous
avons massivement recruté les apprentis
plus de 30 000 pour l'année 2022
deuxième élément l'État s'est engagé
vous le savez auprès des employeurs
territoriaux et compte maintenir cette
engagement c'est 15 millions d'euros sur
les lignes de mon ministère 15 millions
d'euros de France compétences et ça
marche pour l'année dernière il y avait
un objectif de 8000 apprentis dans la
fonction publique territoriale il a été
largement dépassé alors d'ici quelques
jours nous signerons avec le CNFPT que
vous avez mentionné monsieur le sénateur
une nouvelle convention pour l'exercice
2025 le CNFPT prend des engagements
celui de financer pour les collectivités
au moins 9000 apprentis dans les
exercices qui viennent année après année
et je prends des engagements puisque les
crédits de mon ministère seront
maintenus 45 millions d'euros pour les
trois prochaines années pour nous donner
de la visibilité mais monsieur sénateur
et c'est la troisième chose que je
voulais vous dire je ne veux pas
m'arrêter là je crois que tous ensemble
nous pouvons faire de l'apprentissage
une vraie voix de pré recrutement pour
la fonction publique comment expliquer
aujourd'hui qu'à l'issue d'un contrat
d'apprentissage parfois 18 mois quand y
compris l'employeur territorial parfois
la collectivité est jeune apprenti
veulent pouvoir embaucher c'est-à-dire
titulariser l'apprenti dans la fonction
publique il faut qu'il puisse repasser
par la case concours passer une année à
préparer un concours administratif nous
perdons aujourd'hui les apprentis je
veux faire en sorte et je vous ferai des
propositions en ce sens dans les
prochains mois que nous puissions lever
cette obligation du concours à la fin
des contrats d'apprentissage et
permettre une titularisation directe je
crois que c'est comme ça moyen à l'appui
que nous gagnerons les batailles
d'apprentissage dans la fonction
publique
oui merci monsieur missoui nous croyons
à l'apprentissage mais nécessaire de
mieux cibler la politique en matière
d'apprentissage dans la fonction
publique et le désengagement uniatéral
de l'État pour le financement a pour
conséquence de peser sur les finances
des collectivités locales encore un
transfert de charges qui n'est pas
acceptable pour les élus locaux et qui
est dommageable pour les jeunes en
attente de formation merci la parole est
à notre collègue Olivier Jacquin pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicains merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre des Transports
allez vous tenir vos engagements le 22
mars dernier auditionné à l'Assemblée
nationale Bruno Le Maire annonçait
saisir le Conseil d'État pour étudier la
possibilité de raccourcir les durées des
concessions autoroutières il écartait de
fait les deux autres options mises sur
la table par l'Inspection générale des
finances dans un rapport révélé par Le
Canard enchaîné à savoir la diminution
des prix et le prélèvement sur les
bénéfices des sociétés concessionnaires
nous avons appris la semaine dernière
une nouvelle fois par voie de presse que
le Conseil d'État aurait rendu son avis
il privilégierait une hausse de la
fiscalité sur les concessions que le
ministre de l'Économie considérait en
mars être je cite une impasse compte
tenu du caractère stratégique des
autoroutes tant pour l'aménagement du
territoire que pour la transition
écologique des transports et à moins de
10 ans de la fin des premiers contrats
allez vous publier la saisine et la vie
du Conseil d'État comme vous étiez
engagé auprès de notre collègue député
socialiste Christine Pirès bonne le 3
mai dernier par ailleurs quand
allez-vous enfin lancer les assises des
autoroutes que vous nous promettez
depuis trois mois je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
monsieur BECHU
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Jacquin
compte tenu des textes dont vous êtes
l'auteur des prises de parole à
répétition sur ce sujet je ne suis pas
surpris de vous trouver comme étant
l'auteur de cette question vous pouvez
éventuellement être surpris que je sois
le répondant mais je le redis l'absence
de Clément bonne me conduit à remplacer
mon ministre délégué sur ce sujet et à
vous répondre
vous avez parfaitement suivi les
épisodes précédents et dans les épisodes
précédents précisément dans les réponses
qui ont pu être faites dans cette
émission par Bruno Le Maire par Clément
baume dans le cadre des commissions
dédiées nous avons évoqué le fait que
nous étions dans un cadre particulier
qui était celui des concessions avec des
règles juridiques et donc on a joint le
geste à la parole et le Conseil d'État
était saisi de deux questions peut-on
raccourcir unilatéralement une durée de
concession sans être amené à la
compenser de manière intégrale la
réponse est non
les raisons qui permettraient d'aller
justifier l'intérêt général ne peuvent
pas tenir à une appréciation éventuelle
d'un niveau de rentabilité tant que la
durée globale de concession n'est pas
terminée parce qu'on ne peut pas
apprécier seulement sur une partie du
temps ce que produit sur la totalité de
la concession le résultat économique
global et si nous le faisions il faudra
à ce moment-là qu'on compense
financièrement intégralement à coups de
dizaines de milliards d'euros les années
dont on a pu très le contrat tel qu'il a
été signé la deuxième question c'est
peut-on taxer
avec un biais l'IS A B C de 33 à 25% des
calculs de rentabilité c'était établies
sur une base éventuelle qui était celle
du niveau de fiscalité existante le
Conseil d'État dit quoi il dit un c'est
possible mais vous devez considérer les
concessions comme une catégorie homogène
vous ne pouvez pas considérer qu'il y
aurait d'un côté les concessions
d'autoroute et de l'autre d'autres
formes de concession nationale qui
échapperait à la même approche d'une
évolution de la fiscalité sur la durée
qui modifierait les conditions initiales
qui avaient été imaginées sous cette
réserve d'homogénéité des dispositifs
fiscaux sont possibles vous savez que
nous travaillons au financement de la
transition écologique que le financement
de cette transition écologique et en
particulier le plan qui concerne les
transports passent par le fait que nous
puissions verdir ou aller chercher des
dépenses brunes pour faire en sorte
d'avoir des recettes vertes c'est ce à
quoi nous sommes précisément en train de
travailler
[Applaudissements]
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
des collectivités pour la précision de
votre réponse dans ce domaine mais vous
assumez d'être favorable aux concessions
et défendez un modèle déséquilibré vous
obligeant à quémander des risques
tournent pour les usagers spolier comme
le dernier sketch des chats vacance
l'état régulateur doit reprendre la main
et préparer véritablement la précession
écrire et lancer de nouveaux contrats
ces cinq ans de travail le Sénat vous le
répète depuis 2020 d'autres modèles
existent avec notre groupe nous avons
proposé la création d'un épic route de
France qui gèrerait l'ensemble du réseau
routier national alors des battons-en
enfin c'est l'intérêt des Français des
entreprises des territoires et du climat
je vous remercie
la parole est à notre collègue
Jean-Claude Angleur pour le groupe les
républicain
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre le 8 novembre 2022 le président
de la République présentant le plan
France 2030 déclarait son ambition de
faire de la France le leader de
l'hydrogène des carbonées est fixait
l'objectif d'un renforcement de la
stratégie nationale hydrogène sous 6
mois 6 mois plus tard nous y sommes le
23 juin c'est la direction de Bosch
Allemagne qui s'exprime et annonce sa
décision de suspendre le projet fresh
tout d'ici la fin de l'année et pour
plusieurs années jusqu'à ce que le
marché de l'hydrogène soit établi du
règlement le projet fresh tout vise à
développer la pile combustible à
hydrogène destinée à remplacer le moteur
diesel utilisé dans le transport c'est
le projet de reconversion industrielle
du site Bosch donner le château
usine historique de fabrication des
injecteurs et bougies de moteur diesel
condamnés en 2020 par l'abandon
précipité du diesel
la déclaration de l'industriel est un
coût de tonnerre dans le ciel avey ce
choix sans explication et sans
informations préalable apparaît comme
une remise en cause des engagements pris
auprès des syndicats des élus locaux et
de l'état car l'équipementier s'est
engagé à maintenir 250 emplois
reconvertis sur les technologies
hydrogène en 2028 en contrepartie de la
transformation industrielle l'annonce de
gauche c'est une condamnation des 250
derniers emplois or monsieur le ministre
depuis cette annonce la semaine dernière
vous n'avez fait aucune déclaration
alors que la stratégie nationale
d'hydrogène que vous défendez vise à
développer les véhicules lourds propres
et construire en France une filière
industrielle créatrice de 50 à 150 000
emplois que fait le gouvernement pour le
développement du projet de reconversion
de l'usine Bosch donner le château que
faites-vous pour les 250 emplois à
Vérone et à convertir et pérenniser
pour vous répondre la parole des
communistes délégués en charge de
l'Industrie monsieur Lescure
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur merci pour votre question qui
me permet du coup de m'exprimer
officiellement et publiquement sur ce
sujet vous le savez la sortie programmée
du véhicule thermique est un vent de
face extrêmement important pour
l'industrie automobile traditionnelle et
nous avons le temps c'est d'ici 2035
mais nous devons adapter l'appareil de
production à ce nouveau défi Bosch est
un grand groupe européen très présent en
France plus de 6000 emplois à ce stade
dont 1200 en Aveyron à Rodez
la décision prise par le groupe bouche
annonçait à Bosch pardon annoncé la
semaine dernière nous indiquant que le
projet de diversification sur
l'hydrogène que vous avez très bien
écrit n'était plus suffisamment rentable
à court terme pour l'envisager d'ici
2028 ne doit en aucun cas je vais être
très clair changer en quoi que ce soit
les engagements du Groupe Bosch pris
dans le cas d'un accord courageux de la
part des salariés avec les organisations
syndicales en décembre 2021 j'ai échangé
avec tous les élus aujourd'hui avec vous
hier avec les députés à l'Assemblée
nationale avec madame la présidente de
région monsieur le Président du
département et Monsieur le Maire de
Rodez nous sommes tous alignés nous
devons nous assurer que Bosch tiendra
ses engagements mon équipe est déjà en
relation avec les organisations
syndicales mais aussi la direction
France de Bosch mais vous le savez cette
décision elle sera prise en Allemagne
j'ai déjà appris contact avec la
direction allemande avec laquelle je
vais échanger de manière formelle dans
les jours qui viennent mon message sera
clair les engagements doivent être tenus
hydrogène ou autre chose la Reval la
revitalisation du site et le maintien de
250 emplois où la met mentionné dans
l'hydrogène mais de 100 de plus l'emploi
total c'était 500 on est aujourd'hui à
1200 on doit s'assurer qu'en 2028 500
employés travaillant sur ce site que ce
soit l'hydrogène ou autre chose je m'y
engage devant vous et évidemment
j'informerai tous les élus du
département de la région de l'avancée de
ces discussions merci sur glace quelques
secondes
merci monsieur le ministre pour ces
réponses mais j'allais vous inviter à
venir en Aveyron avec votre collègue
monsieur Dupont-Moretti qui vient
vendredi pour expliquer cela à tous les
élus et tous les syndicats etc en
Aveyron voilà merci
la parole de notre collègue Olivier
Hinault pour le groupe de l'Union
européenne
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre ma question concerne la récente
expulsion de Monsieur Saya dont l'arrêté
date du 26 octobre dernier ce citoyen
algérien était connu comme président de
la mosquée Asuna à Hautmont dans
laquelle je cite l'arrêté il dit il
dispensait un islam salafiste et
notamment des prêches marquées par des
propos légitimement le jihad armé
appelant à la violence à la haine à la
discrimination et à la commission
d'actes de terrorisme excusé du peu que
cette personne en rupture avec les
valeurs de la République soient
retournés en Algérie tant mieux c'est le
résultat de la volonté de l'État et je
salue la prise de position de ce jour
dans la presse du préfet de région mais
aussi et surtout du courage et de la
pertinence des choix du maire d'Aumont
Stéphane villemotte et je veux saluer
son courage son courage d'avoir refusé
le mariage de cette personne qui aurait
sans doute empêché son expulsion or pour
avoir dénoncé cette instrumentalisation
du mariage par cet individu
le maire d'Aumont s'est trouvé sous le
feu de menace d'insultes et
d'intimidation fallait-il à ce propos
laisser s'organiser ce dimanche la
manifestation de soutien à Monsieur Saya
qui n'avait pas d'autres objets que de
faire psychologiquement pression sur le
maire d'Aumont or c'est bien ce dont il
s'agit une forme de violence
psychologique non sont de plus en plus
souvent victimes les élus les violences
physiques aux élus sont intolérables
mais les violents se psychologiques le
sont tout autant elles sont moins
visibles mais plus sournoises plus
fréquente et tout autant grave et
insupportable alors Monsieur le Ministre
ma question est limpide comment
voyez-vous l'accompagnement de l'État
quand les mers sont confrontés à
l'évidence à des mariages de
complaisance ou pire à des mariages
forcés et parfois à une forme de
violence psychologique pour les
prononcer contre leur Grais je vous
remercie
répondre la parole est obligé de
l'intérieur que Gérald Darmanin merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Olivier Hainaut merci d'avoir
souligné l'action de l'État sur
l'expulsion de Monsieur Saya qui en
effet depuis trop longtemps dans le
Territoire du Nord où vous êtes élu
prenez un islam salafiste est en lien
avec une mosquée qui en effet faisait
l'apologie du terrorisme et après
beaucoup de démarches administratives
comme d'autres va faire plus médiatique
que nous avons connu récemment a pu être
expulsé en effet du territoire national
je voudrais moi aussi remercier le
travail très courageux du maire de
Monsieur Stéphane villemotte parce que
c'est son action avec le préfet de
département des services de
renseignements qu'on a réussi à rétablir
leur public et une certaine idée que
nous avons de la France et de la
pratique religieuse dans notre pays
Monsieur le Maire a été menacé et il a
été reçu vous le savez pour la 48 heures
par Monsieur préfet de département qui
en effet à dans La Voix du Nord
aujourd'hui
jamais été réseaux sociaux j'ai demandé
au préfet du Nord d'interdire la
prochaine manifestation j'ai demandé au
préfet du Nord de se saisir de la loi
séparatisme que vous avez voté et qui
permet de créer un délit justement de
pression contre le service public et
notamment les élus et qu'il saisisse par
article 40 procureur de la République
pour pouvoir poursuivre évidemment ceux
qui font des pressions plus ou moins
directes contre Monsieur le Maire et son
conseil municipal je veux d'ailleurs
dire que les policiers qui ont procédé
parfois aux interventions ont vu leur
nom publier et que je souhaite également
que le préfet puisse poursuivre enfin
poursuivre par le procureur de la
République ces pressions inacceptables
je veux dire que procédant des mariages
sous l'autorité monsieur le garder ceux
parce que comme vous le savez quand le
maire Marie il le fait en lien avec le
procureur de la République nous y
travaillons avec Monsieur le gardeesso
pour que les enquêtes de moralité
lorsque les mers considèrent qu'un
mariage n'est pas un mariage qu'on
pourrait évoquer comme étant un mariage
d'amour en mariage librement consenti
alors que nous puissions aider les
maires à prendre les mesures de refus je
vais leur dire que ceux qui ont un EQF
et qui peuvent se marier depuis la loi
ne permettent pas de rester sur le
territoire national et perçoit quand
même expulsables et c'est une très bonne
chose et je veux surtout dire que nous
donnerons les moyens avec Christophe
Vichy locaux avec
Eric Dupond-Moretti de protéger les mers
c'est le cas monsieur homo qui vous le
savez depuis sainte depuis quelques
jours et par suivants protégés par les
forces du ministères de l'Intérieur
[Applaudissements]
la parole est notre collègue Jean-Louis
Masson pour la Réunion administrative
des sénateurs ne finiront sur la liste
d'aucun groupe vous avez la parole
en raison de l'incohérence du
recensement des logements à Susie à la
taxe d'habitation plus de 40 % des
contribuables n'ont pas répondu c'est le
cas de plusieurs millions de foyers qui
continuent à effectuer leur déclaration
de revenus sur papier et qui n'ont même
pas été informés de ce fait les services
fiscaux viennent de leur adresser une
circulaire leur demandant de se
renseigner auprès des services fiscaux
ou de téléphoner à un numéro national en
08 pour connaître la procédure à suivre
or c'est circulaire est d'une totalement
mauvaise foi car des files d'attente de
plusieurs heures ont été constatées pour
l'accès physique au service fiscaux et
lorsqu'on compose même 20 fois de suite
le numéro national en 08 il est toujours
occupé selon les syndicats en une seule
journée plus de 94.000 personnes ont été
victimes de cette incurie en outre plus
de 20 000 courriers sont par exemple en
attente de réponse dans les
Bouches-du-Rhône plus de 3000 dans les
Hautes-Pyrénées il est totalement
inacceptable une fois qu'une fois de
plus les responsables du ministère des
Finances marginalisent ceux qui n'ont
pas accès au numérique je vous demande
donc monsieur le ministre pourquoi le
formulaire papier pré-rempli n'a pas été
adressé par la poste au contribuable
concernés comme c'est le cas pour toutes
les déclarations d'impôt sur le revenu
lorsque les gens ne sont pas branchés
sur internet en outre plusieurs
directeurs départementaux ayant dit que
pour 2023 il n'y aurait pas de pénalité
financière en cas de non-réponse je vous
demande de confirmer cette annonce et
j'insiste sur ce point en souhaitant que
vous ne me répondiez par oui ou par non
et pas par une réponse à moitié
fileteuse ou on ne comprend rien
quand vous répondre la parole est
aubilise déléguée en charge des comptes
publics
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur au moment de la suppression de
la taxe d'habitation a été décidé on
remonte donc à 2019 pour la décision de
mettre en place une déclaration
d'occupation elle est importante pour
les communes puisque les communes
continuent à recevoir une taxe
d'habitation sur les résidences
secondaires et d'ailleurs le Parlement a
décidé d'élargir la liste des communes
qui peuvent majorer de 60% la taxe
d'habitation sur les résidences
secondaires si on veut qu'elle puisse
recevoir les justes recettes auxquelles
elles ont droit il faut que nous soyons
en capacité de savoir précisément quels
sont les résidences secondaires on ne
veut pas que des contribuables se
fassent taxer sur leur résidence
principale une taxe d'habitation
résidence secondaire ou que des
résidences secondaires échappent à la
taxe d'habitation liée aux résidences
secondaires je pense que les communes
seraient les premières à s'en plaindre
d'où le choix à l'époque en 2019 de
mettre en place cette déclaration
d'occupation effectivement ça a
entraînait un certain nombre de
difficultés pour des contribuables pas
nécessairement sur le fait qu'il faut
déclarer son bien et son occupation mais
sur les données cadastrales que tout le
monde n'a pas l'habitude de manipuler
même si pour le délai qui était fixé à
la fin du mois de juin c'est seulement
la déclaration d'occupation du logement
et l'identité de la personne qui est
locataire si c'est le cas qui était
nécessaire raison pour laquelle on a
décidé un certain nombre de choses et
notamment de décaler d'un mois le délai
donc vous voyez bien ça répond à votre
deuxième question que notre objectif ça
n'est pas d'aller entre guillemets
pénaliser les contribuables de bonne foi
ça n'est pas l'objet au contraire ce
qu'on veut c'est accompagner et à ce
titre je veux saluer les agents des
finances publiques qui répondent à des
centaines de milliers d'appels qui ont
rempli au lieu et place des
contribuables plusieurs centaines de
milliers de déclarations qui continuent
à travailler il y a eu effectivement un
pic d'appel au moment où la fameuse
circulaire que vous avez évoquée a été
diffusée mais on constate 40% d'appel en
moins depuis la semaine dernière et des
files d'attentes qui se réduisent mais
si on a donné un délai supplémentaire
monsieur le sénateur c'est justement
pour pouvoir accompagner les
contribuables et que personne ne soit
pénalisé je vous le dis c'est cette
ligne de conduite qui continuera à nous
guider encore une fois pour une réforme
et une déclaration qui doit se faire au
bénéfice des communes et des seules
communes pour qu'elles reçoivent les
recettes auxquelles elles ont droit
monsieur
mes messieurs monsieur le ministre vous
vous moquez du monde je n'ai pas répondu
à ma question je vous ai demandé
pourquoi on n'a pas envoyé à tous ceux
par papiers la demande et vous allez
absolument pas répondu je vous ai
demandé si c'était vrai que il y aurait
pas de pénalité financière je vous
demandais de répondre par oui ou par non
vous avez pas répondu alors si on te
vous moquez du Parlement monsieur le
ministre
mais
nous en avons terminé avec les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement pour cette
session ordinaire mes chers collègues
mais nous aurons le plaisir de nous
retrouver dans le cadre de la session
extraordinaire le mercredi 5 juin à 15
heures
juillet
je vais suspendre la séance ce sera
reprise à
16h35 pour la suite de l'examen du
projet de loi relatif à la programmation
militaire la séance est suspendue